let's imagine that instead of having two
charges we just have one charge by
itself sitting in a vacuum sitting in
space this charge here and let's say
it's charged as I don't know it's Q
that's some number you know but whatever
it is that's his charge and I want to
know if I were to place another charge
close to this Q somehow you know somehow
within its you could call it sphere of
influence what's going to happen to that
other charge what's going to be the net
impact on it and we know if this has
some charge you know if we put another
charge here you know this is I don't
know one Coulomb and we put another
charge here that's one Coulomb that
they're going to you know if they're
both positive they were going to repel
each other so there will be some force
that pushes the next charge away if it's
a if it's a negative charge and I put it
here it'll be even a stronger force it
pulls it in because it'll be closer so
in general there's this notion of what
we can call an electric field around
discharge and what's an electric field
it's it's I mean you can we can debate
whether it really exists but what it
allows us to do is imagine that somehow
this this charge is affecting the space
around it in some way that when I
whenever I put it's creating a field
that whenever I put another charge in
that field I can predict how the field
will affect that charge so let's put it
in a little more quantitative terms so I
stop confusing you so Coulomb's law told
us that the force between two charges
the force between two charges is going
to equal two Coulomb's constant times
and in this case the first charge is is
big Q and let's say that the second
whatever notional charge that I
eventually put in this field is small Q
and then you divide by the distance
between them sometimes it's it's called
R because you can kind of view the
distance as the radial distance between
the two charges so sometimes it says R
squared but it's the distance between
them so what what we want to do if we
want to calculate the field we want to
figure out how much force is there
placed
per charge at any point around this Q so
it say you know the given distance out
here you know this distance we want to
know for given Q what is the force going
to be so we can do is we could take this
equation up here and divide both sides
by this
q and say okay the force and I will
arbitrarily switch colors the force per
charge at this point you know whatever
let's call that D 1 is equal to
Coulomb's constant times the charge of
the particle that's creating the field
divided by well in this case at D 1 and
D 1 squared right or we could say in
general and this is going to be this is
this is the definition of the electric
field right and actually the well this
is this is the electric field at the
point D 1 and if we wanted a more
general definition of the electric field
it'll be you know we'll just make this a
general variable so instead of having a
particular distance we'll define the
field for all distances away from the
point Q so the electric field could be
defined as Coulomb's constant times the
charge creating the field divided by the
distance squared the distance we we are
away from the charge so essentially
we've defined if you give me a force and
a point around this around this charge
anywhere I can now tell you the exact
force for example if I told you that I
have a I don't know a 1 Coulomb let's go
say a what a minus 1 Coulomb charge
that's and and the distance is equal to
oh I don't know the distance is equal to
let's say let's make it easy let's say 2
meters so first of all we can say in
general that what is the electric field
2 meters away from so what is the
electric field out here if this is 2
right and it's going to be 2 meters away
its radial so it's actually along this
whole circle what is the electric field
there well the electric field at that
point is going to be equal to what and
it's also a vector quantity right
because we're dividing a vector quantity
by a scalar a scalar quantity charge so
the electric field at that point is
going to be K times whatever charge it
is divided by 2 meters so divided by 2
squared so that's for right distance
squared and so if I know the electric
field at any given point and then I say
well what happens if I put a negative 1
Coulomb charge there all I have to do is
say well the force is going to be equal
to the charge that I place there times
the electric field at that point right
so in this case we said the electric
field at this point is equal to and then
and the units for electric field are our
Newton's per Coulomb and that makes
sense right because it's force divided
by charge so Newton's per Coulomb so if
we know that the electric charge but let
me put some real numbers here let's say
that this is I don't know it's going to
be a really large number but let's say
this let me let me pick out a smaller
number let's say this is 1 times 10 to
the minus 6 coulombs right if that's 1
times 10 in the set net minus 6 coulombs
what is the electric field at that point
and let me switch colors again
what's the electric field at that point
well the electric field at that point is
going to be equal to Coulomb's constant
which is 9 times 10 to the 9th times the
charge generating the field times 1
times 10 to the minus 6
it's coulombs and then we are 2 meters
away so 2 squared so that equals to C 9
times 10 to the 3rd divided by 4 so I
don't know what is that 2.5 times 10 to
the 3rd or 2500 2500 Newton's per
Coulomb so we know that this is
generating a field that when were 2
meters away at this you know at a radius
of 2 meters so roughly that whole area
you know that circle around it this is
generating a field that if I were to put
let's say I were to place a 1 Coulomb
charge here let's say I place a 1
Coulomb charge the force exerted on that
1 Coulomb charge is going to be equal to
1 Coulomb times the electric field times
2500 Newton's per Coulomb so the
coulombs can't slide and we'll have 2500
Newton's which is a lot and that's
because 1 1 Coulomb is a very very large
charge and then a question you should
ask yourself if this is 1
times 10 to the negative 6 Coulomb this
is one Coulomb in which direction will
the force be well they're both positive
so the force is going to be outwards all
right so let's take this notion and see
if we can somehow draw an electric field
around a particle just to get an
intuition of what happens when we later
put a charge anywhere near the particle
so there's a couple of ways to visualize
an electric field one way to visualize
it is if I have a let's say I have a
point charge here Q what would happen if
I what would be the path of a positive
charge if I placed it someplace near
this Q well if I put a positive charge
here then and this Q is positive that
positive charge is just going to
accelerate outward right it's just gonna
go straight out and it's gonna it's
gonna go but it's going to accelerate an
ever slowing rate right because here
when you're really close the outward
force is very strong and then as you get
further and further away the the elect
the electrostatic force from this charge
becomes weaker and weaker right or you
could say the field becomes weaker
weaker but that's the path of a of a it
will just be radially outward of a of a
positive test charge and then if I put
it here well it would be radially out
radially outward that way and it
wouldn't curve the way I drew it it
would be a straight line I check she's a
line tool if I did it here it'd be like
that but then I can't draw the arrows if
I was here it would go out like that and
you I think you get the picture
at any point a positive test charge
would just go straight out away from our
charge Q and to some degree one measure
of actually and these are called
electric field lines and one measure of
how strong the field is is you could
actually if you actually took a unit
area so if you actually took a unit area
and you saw how dense the field lines
are so here they're relatively sparse
well if I if I did that same area I
don't know up here I don'ts not that
obvious I'm getting more field lines in
but actually that's not a good way to
view it because I'm I'm covering so much
area let me
undo both of them you can ratify had a
lot more lines if I did this area for
example in that area I'm capturing two
of these field lines well if I did that
exact same area out here
I'm only capturing one of the field
lines although you could imagine there
you could have a bunch more in between
here and that makes sense right because
as you get closer and closer to the to
the source of the electric field the
charge gets stronger another way that
you could have done this and this would
have actually shown probably more
clearly shown the magnitude of the field
at any point is you could have you say
okay if that's my charge Q you could say
well really close the field is strong so
at this point you know the vector is the
Newton's per Coulomb is that strong you
know that's strong that's strong that's
strong and you have to we're just taking
sample points you can't possibly draw
them at every single point you know so
at that point though that's the vector
that's the electric field vector but
then if we go a little bit further out
the vector is going to be you know it
falls off it gets this one should be
shorter than this one should be even
shorter right you could pick any point
and you could actually calculate the
electric field vector and it the further
you go out the shorter and shorter the
electric field vectors get and so in
general you know you we could there's
all sorts of things you can draw the
electric fields for you if we had a
let's say that this is a positive charge
and that this is a negative charge let
me switch colors so I don't have to
erase things if I had to draw the path
of a positive test charge it would go
out radially from this charge right but
then as it goes out it'll start being
attracted to this one the closer it gets
to the negative and then it'll curve in
to the negative charge alright and these
arrows go like this and if I went from
here the positive one will be repelled
really strong really strong it'll go
really it'll accelerate fast and it'll
its rate of acceleration will slow down
but then as it gets closer to the
negative one it'll speed up again and
then that would be its path and
similarly if there was a positive test
charge here its path would be like that
right if there was here its path would
be like that if it was here its path
would be like that
if it was there maybe its path is like
that
and at some point its path might just
you know never get to that pot you know
this out here might just go straight out
that way I mean at some point right I
mean that one would just go straight out
and here the field lines would just come
in right a positive test charge would
just be naturally attracted to that
negative charge so that's in general
what electric field lines show and we
could use our little area method and see
that over here if we picked a given area
the electric field is much weaker than
if we picked that same area right here
we're getting more field lines in than
we do right there so that hopefully
gives you a little sense for what an
electric field is it's really just a way
of visualizing what the impact would be
on a test charge if you bring it close
to another charge and hopefully you know
a little bit about Coulomb's constant
and you know let's let's just do a very
simple I'm getting this out of the AP
physics book but they say let's do a
little simple problem calculate the
static electric force between a 6 times
10 to the negative 6 Coulomb charge so 6
times I don't know that's not an
electric field over here it says what is
the force acting on an electron placed
in an electric in an external electric
field where the electric field is
they're saying it is 100 Newton's per
Coulomb at that point wherever the
electron is so the force on that the
force is in general is just going to be
the charge times the electric field and
they said it's an electron so what's the
charge of an electron well we know it's
negative and then in the first video we
learned that its charges 1.6 times 10 to
the negative 19 coulombs 10 to the
negative 19 coulombs times 100 Newton's
per Coulomb the coulombs cancel out and
this is 10 squared right this is 10 to
the positive 2 so it'll be so 10 to the
minus 19 times 10 to the positive 2 the
force will be minus 1 point 6 times 10
to the minus 17 Newtons so the problems
are pretty simple I think the more
important thing with electric fields is
to really understand intuitively what's
going on and
and kind of where the strength you know
how its stronger near the point charges
and how it gets weaker as goes away and
what the field lines depict and how they
can be used to at least approximate the
strength of the field I will see you in
the next video